for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy
okay so I've already talked about that
you recycle twice before once with the
sort of overview video and that second
one with some more details but in this
one I'm going to include the actual
enzymes of the cycle as well as how it
how the urea cycle fits with the
glutamate dehydrogenase and glues
Hammond ace enzymes that we just learned
a little while ago okay so here we're
starting off with glutamine and with
glutamate which are both amino acids
that are coming in with with these amino
groups right with these nitrogens or
with this amide nitrogen here basically
they're coming in carrying nitrogen's
from elsewhere they're carrying
nitrogens that we need to excrete so
they're gonna go from the cytosol of the
liver into the mitochondrial matrix and
the glutamine specifically will be
turned into glutamate in the
mitochondrial matrix of the liver via
the glue Tammany's reaction sort of
hydrolyzing off that a my nitrogen so
that a my nitrogen will end up as an
ammonium ion right here and then the
glutamine upon losing this amide
nitrogen becomes glutamate
now that glutamate can undergo the
glutamate dehydrogenase reaction and of
course that will produce nadh or NADPH
as as well as alpha ketoglutarate here
and it'll also free up an ammonium ion
okay so we're basically getting the
nitrogens from the glutamine and from
the glutamate ending up here okay
now not all that good may want to go
through the glutamate dehydrogenase
reaction some of it might undergo and
actually will undergo a transamination
with oxaloacetate
this is specifically gonna be catalyzed
by a sparked eight amino transferase and
that's because oxaloacetate here is the
alpha keto acid of aspartate so us part
eight will be produced here we'll see
why that's important in just a moment
okay so the idea though is that we're
going to basically rip off the
nitrogen's from the glutamine and from
the glutamate and they're going to end
up either here as free ammonium ion in
the mitochondrial matrix or on us part
eight okay or I should say and and or
okay now we have this free ammonium ion
here and that is going to be turned into
carbamoyl phosphate here by adding a
bicarbonate or carbon dioxide depending
on how you look at it and we're also
going to invest two ATP's here and then
we'll get out to a DPS and inorganic
phosphate and then one of the phosphate
groups will end up right here on Camp
carbamoyl phosphate and this is gonna be
catalyzed by carbamoyl phosphate
synthetase one which is actually the
committed step when it comes to going
through the urea cycle and it is
allosteric ly regulated and we'll see
that some more details on that in the
next video
okay so then we actually have the urea
cycle there carbamoyl phosphate is ready
to go and it is going to combine with
ornithine where the first step of the
urea cycle is actually happening in the
mitochondrial matrix so we're gonna
start off over here with ornithine and
the ornithine is going to be converted
into citrulline where this portion of
the carbamoyl phosphate is going to
attach to ornithine horn fiends side
chain amino group and we'll get
citrulline which looks like this so this
is this portion here right is coming
from the carbamoyl phosphate this first
step of the urea cycle is catalyzed by
an enzyme called ornithine
transcarbamylase okay now once we have
that citrulline that Ciccolini is going
to exit the mitochondrial matrix out
into the cytosol where the rest of the
urea cycle will occur
okay so now we've got this citrulline
out here over to the top right and then
we're gonna have the second step of the
urea cycle that's actually broken up
into parts a and B and they're both
gonna be catalyzed by Arjun Oh sucks
nascent the tastes okay so this at the
taste is going to produce arjuna
succinate which we see here and part in
Part A of the reaction we're going to
add an ATP where the the a MP portion
ends up on attached to the citrulline
and the pyrophosphate falls off so we
get that a MP portion there attached to
this citrulline to become the sit really
OAA Citra leo a MP intermediate which is
going to join is going to have a spar
tape it's essentially a MP is activated
such that aspartate can come in and
basically take take the spot of this a
MP portion okay so where did this
aspartate come from specifically well it
came from the aspartate that we created
back in the mitochondrial matrix up here
right there via that transamination
reaction that aspartate is gonna come
out into the cytosol to be a part of
this reaction okay so it's gonna replace
the a MP and people fall off and we'll
produce our you know succinate okay so
now we've got this nitrogen of aspartate
attached here right we already had these
two nitrogens already there i'm sure
these two here okay so let's get rid of
those circles okay so now we've got our
Jinnah succinate this portion of the
molecule being the part that's pretty
much arginine and this portion right
here being the succinate portion and
that portion is actually gonna fall off
in the next step as a fumarate producing
arginine here the rest will become an
arginine
and that is going to be catalyzed by our
gino succinate so it's going to cut our
genetics innate into arginine and
fumarate and that fumarate can be
converted into male 8 finance I'm called
cytosolic humor race just humor race
just in the cytosol and this is
important because this male 8 can go
back into the mitochondrial matrix and
go through the TCA cycle right and go
through the TCA cycle to give some nadh
which can give us some energy all right
so then this arginine that is produced
in this third step here this arginine is
going to be hydrolyzed we're gonna have
this portion out here
hydrolyzed off as urea and of course
that urea can be safely excreted in the
urine in the urine safely excreted in
the urine and the rest of the molecule
ends up regenerating ornithine and that
that that fourth step there of the urea
cycle is catalyzed by our Gen ace of
course once we make that your that that
urea and that or anything that ornithine
can go back into the mitochondrial
matrix for basically another round of
the urea cycle with another carbamoyl
phosphate so that's hopefully a better
big-picture view of everything that's
going on as far as the urea cycle and
things that kind of lead up to it anyway
I hope that video was helpful thank you
for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying